okay good morning once again and when
code to NDC Copenhagen my name is Mauro
and as you get may guess by my accent
I'm Italian up to you to this to decide
if you want to be sorry because of my
accent or because of the fact that I'm
Italian
no I'm Aeromotive worker so I'm fully
100% remote as all my colleagues by the
way but the flat we live in is
unfortunately too small so I don't have
a room in my flat to work from so I
rented an office that there is a couple
of kilometres far away from where I live
and I usually bike right there so and my
favorite snacks are bananas so can you
imagine what happens when you put a
banana in the backpack while bike riding
so if you experience that you realize
that it's a interesting failure so
you're basically your snack is dead and
the backpack as well so the first thing
I did after experiencing that for a
couple of times was to head to Hamazon
and look for a banana protector whose
goal was to basically save my snacks and
the backpackers were oh I got to this
page looked for the best product with
the best reviews because you know that
matters a lot and finally I added the
product to the shopping cart and as soon
as I added the product to the shopping
cart the architect that constantly lives
in the back of my mind
popped up saying how such a thing could
be designed so it imagined ourselves
sitting on the other side of the screen
inside the Amazon offices coding such a
thing outlook likes so at the first look
it sounds like a very nice looking
aggregate doesn't it
we have a shopping cart it's a concept
it's something that it's really really
aligned with the user mental model
businesspeople talks about shopping
carts all the time
talks about adding products to the
shopping cart changing the quantity
removing products for the shop from the
shopping cart so why not modeling that
as an aggregate it even has behaviors if
we look at the web page we have the
delete behavior to remove something from
the shopping cart the save for later
behavior to move that outside of the
shopping cart on the same in the same
area so that I can remind myself I want
to buy it sooner or later and I can
change the quantity so it sounds it fits
the perfect definition of an aggregate
data and behaviors so why not let's try
to apply a few business requirements to
such a nice-looking aggregate then the
first one sounds like a simple one we
want to be sure that the price doesn't
really change when an item isn't a
shopping cart so we don't want to
transfer entry
basically speed money from our users
that seems like a fair one so pricing is
something that is not really owned by
the shopping cart so there's someone we
can call the sales team or the sales
aggregate that owns the price so it
sounds legitimate at this point to say
well you know what whenever we add an
item to the shopping cart
why not copying the price over there the
normalization for the Wayne and will we
obtain is basically we satisfy the the
business requirement because now
whenever the price change it will change
here and it won't affect in any way the
shopping cart so we'll save from that
perspective okay so far so good let's go
ahead with the second one the business
comes to us and says well you know what
I'd like to be able to show on the
product way
on the shopping cart whenever we talk
about products in general the
availability in stock how many items we
have in stock for that specific item
might be a fake information because we
want to try to convince people to buy
stuff that we're running out of stuff
that still be true but it doesn't really
matter B where the number comes from
what the purpose of the number is the it
sounds like it's not really a big deal
once again so we have warehouse that is
the one owning the inventory count they
can now say well whenever we add an item
to the shopping cart we're going to ask
where I was a can you give me the
current inventory of that item and I'm
going to copy over that item to the
shopping cart
so doesn't seem to be a big deal however
we have an interesting problem now
availability changes over time much more
than pricing so that's a first smell
isn't it so what happens is that
whenever the inventory count changes now
warehouse need to do
hey shopping cart or to be precise
shopping cart
do you have an item identified by item
ID ABC in one of your shopping cart if
yes can you please change the quantity
for all of them because it just changed
might be done eventually consistent way
using a method might be done using HTTP
request
no matter the the transport you're using
to try to achieve this goal but you have
this kind of dependency between two
items they should not depend upon each
other so let's go ahead third business
requirement law says unfortunately we
have rules we need to obey to that we
cannot really at least that the they're
all I guess it's the law in the US as
well because this screenshot comes from
the US but the behavior is the same
the Italian website so if the price
changes that item cannot be left in the
shopping cart so because the problem is
users might not realize that the price
changed them we want to sell at the new
price because the price change might be
drastic let's say from 10 dollars to 15
so it's the 50% more so it's not a big
change as a unit but if the 50% more so
law says you cannot leave that the thing
in the shopping cart you need to move it
out so that users cannot unate
vertically I think it's being referred
by it so unexpectedly buy it without
realizing the price change however we as
the company trying to sell stuff we want
to make user aware that well the price
change and it's here and it's there on
the same page it's just outside of your
shopping cart so why not use this save
for later feature something like that so
we want to be able to notify the the
kind of the change increase the decrease
the show the amounts and move the item
outside of the shopping cart into the
saved for later area fine
so now price is not enough in the
shopping cart anymore because in order
to show the difference we need to be
able to keep track of that so we need to
change the shopping cart structure in
order to be able to say well you know
what I have the current price and I have
the last price that represented the time
when the price that the time the item
was added to the cart and the time now
with the prices now so sales now
whenever the price changes needs to
shopping cards do you have
item ABC somewhere if yes can you please
swap the prices and update the current
one with the current price and move the
old one to the last price and please
move it to the save for later so sales
is now dictating to someone else please
do this for me okay it's becoming messy
isn't it so now whenever does a price
change and in a large e-commerce website
that might happen quite frequently and
whenever there's a an inventory change
and that happens a lot we have this now
interesting source of congestion or
contention or we will fighting over kind
of a single resource over here in order
to try to do stuff we should not do from
the outside and if you think about it
the the big picture is even messier so
think about marketing marketing owns the
name of the end the description of the
things that we have in the shopping cart
if we added a name and description here
every single time we add something to
the shopping cart we need to ask
marketing can you please copy over your
stuff here and shipping does the same
so if shipping is responsible for the
delivery type or delivery estimate or
things like that then shipping needs to
be involved whenever we touch the
shopping cart in copying data over and
if something changes in updating data to
the shopping cart
what are we lost immediately here
autonomy is basically gone so one of the
things we strive for that is autonomy in
designing components it's basically
non-existent due to the fact that we
need to have components that clearly
shouldn't be dependent upon each other
we need to have them being able to talk
to each other and even worse being able
to have one component such as for
example sales or the pricing component
whatever you want to call it being able
to dictate to someone else that is not
really under is condemned aircon
trol to do something for me move it to
saved for later that's a behavior that
belongs to the shopping cart
doesn't really belong to sales at least
that's the way the business described
the thing so on in essence the question
we should try to answer is can we get
rid of all this coupling because that's
effectively coupling this many type of
coupling inside here we might have
technical coupling because if we were
you if you if you are using HDPE over
here we're bound to the communication
channel we have temporal coupling
because if you're using HTTP over here
these two guys must be online at the
same time in order to satisfy the
request and if the shopping cart is
overloaded by high throughput as soon as
sales comes in and say hey change the
price the shopping cart might say go
away timeout you cannot do it and then
we have deployment coupling because as
soon as we try to change the shopping
cart and deploy it we might break saves
or warehouse shipping and the other way
around
if shipping needs to change we might
tell lies oh god we need to change the
way shopping carts now behave because we
changed the way we structure our self in
managing delivery estimate whatever
sample is Suites better for us that's
good and then we have people coupling so
teams in a large infrastructure that
should be completely independent such as
well I'm managing inventory I know
nothing about shopping carts I don't
even live in the same time zone as the
team that manages the shopping cart now
I need to be able to talk to the
shopping cart people in order to say
well look I need to deploy can you
please stop applying changes for awhile
because our deployment is so big and
huge and monolithic that we need to stop
you in order to be able to deploy that's
all these are source of coupling they
have different names but in the end on
the
who that this is coupling the fingers
should realize in the end is that the
shopping cart doesn't really exist so
the business talks about the shopping
cart the UI talks about shopping carts
but if we try to decline that concept in
on to the architecture and into the
technical side of things we should
realize such as the spoon doesn't exist
the shopping cart doesn't really exist
or it's not really required to exist
let's put in this way that sounds better
so let's try to decompose the shopping
cart so let's try to bring the aggregate
concept from domains even design to the
next level we have all these actors
aggregates services micro services
autonomous components all these names I
guess that they fit very well into the
picture so you can name all these boxes
using one of these names looking at the
first business requirement we have sales
that needs to deal with prices inside
the shopping cart so let's clear that
apart let's remove the current price
last price in quantity from the shopping
cart and move it under the sales control
so we have a list of items with IDS
prices so current and luster and
quantities quantities are required
because we need to be able to calculate
the draw amount so that the user pays
that's the same thing with warehouse
warehouse needs to deal with inventory
so we need quantity in order to be able
to understand how many items are
currently living in shopping carts so
that we can calculate and forecast the
inventory and let's do the same with
shipping shipping cares about delivery
estimates only so we need the item ID
the quantity so to understand how big
the package will be and understand well
this package shipped to Italy from the
US will take a week so that's the
estimate fine marketing
doesn't really change there's no point
in copying data data over the only good
reason for marketing so in this case
name and description to change our typos
and it's perfectly fine that fixing a
typo
is a kind of normalized operation so
it's immediately reflect refracted
everywhere that information is used so
it's fair to us assume that marketing
doesn't need at all for this specific
requirement this display name and
description somewhere any shopping cart
concept marketing might need a shopping
cart concept to say well I know you know
what I want to understand I want to get
stats about the usage of the shopping
carts I want to get stats about how many
products get in and get out of shopping
carts and understand users behavior and
stuff like that but for for these
purpose marketing doesn't really care
about shopping carts in general do we
need a shopping cart at all at this
point
not really so what we can do is
basically assign the shopping cart
concept as ownership to sales saying you
own the cart ID that means that whenever
if I'm a new user on the website and I
click for the first time ever at the
shopping cart a cart ID must be created
for me sales is the one responsible of
saying here is the new cart ID that's it
that's all what we need in order to say
a cart exists that good enough from even
from the technical perspective to get
this going
what have we done by following this
decomposition approach so if we compare
this picture to the previous one the big
picture where we had many arrows going
crossing effectively crossing boundaries
we still have our rules if you think
about it
but we just follow the coupling so we
accepted that coupling exists it's in
the nature of things so sales is coupled
in some way with the fact that or is
cohesive
should say that is the positive side of
coupling is cohesive we're saying well
we need to update prices in the in
shopping cart but we can do that in our
subdomain or another in our service
boundary or in our bounded context
whatever you want to call it where else
does the same at this point given that
sales all this information what sales
can do as can I do this in the
transaction yes it's my field I own
everything so if we need to be
transactional consistent we can those
two things can live on the same database
that's not the problem at all it's owned
by sales so we can have we can even pay
the price of having the DTC running here
that's not a big problem at all so we
might be have two different sequel
server databases and they DTC in order
to keep the thing consistent and sales
might say well we can pay the price we
have huge machines but we don't want
that distributive transaction to cross
this hard boundary that something should
never happen so what would what we did
basically so far is that we followed the
coupling accepting that some sort of
some form of coupling must exist in a
system in order to achieve the business
goal and we said well let's try to
remove all the coupling the discussing
boundaries and adapt to that the problem
is that we solved one issue and we just
created another one obviously we cannot
ask people to wait in order to
understand how your shopping cart is
composed by you need to go to these four
pages and get the sales view of the
shopping cart
keep tracking your mind of that view ID
in the URL use that on the next page and
connecting your mind the dots
understanding that what was priced at
$10 is the bonanno protector that
doesn't really work so basically
effectively as soon as we split the
information into multiple contexts or
boundaries we're effectively broken the
UI
whatever order let's see the let me use
the term user interface as a more
general thing not necessarily a user in
front of an interface but can be any TI
as well so we've broken the information
that is coming outside from our system
into something else and that something
gas can be a device can be a browser can
be an API consumed by a third party
whatever that third party now has to
query for different API in order to
understand what what's the status of the
shopping cart the easiest solution to
this or read models
so let's me let me throw some technology
on to the problem and solve it using
basically what we can call CQRS at this
point and say well you know what if we
have these five services each one owning
a piece of the information what prevents
me about doing in some way pushing
pulling that doesn't really matter at
this point in some way
put some in some of these information
into a central storage that we can call
the view model storage think about
elastic search for example at this point
and allow the shopping cart to be
queried out of this composed storage
does it work probably the fact that I'm
asking others is a hint that from my
perspective it doesn't really work so
what's the problem with this is that if
we call this a rate model that sounds
fencing and that ain't attractive well I
want rate models I want more technology
I want to be able to play with elastic
search I want to be able to do this
amazing stuff you know what it is it's a
cache that's what it is
so we're basically outsourcing data from
owners to a land of nowhere owned by no
one because there's no ownership inside
the reed model storage and that's what
the cache is we're basically hoping for
the best that the cache is valid
we're basically basing everything about
our business that's the source of truth
because the interface will query that
business decisions a user's decision
will be made out of the cache and the
problem is that we cannot cache
everything I intentionally picked the US
Amazon Web page from Italy because they
cannot ship to my place that means that
I'm logged in using my Italian account
they know all the shipment addresses and
they are on the flying calculating this
cannot be shipped to a tree that means
that this information cannot be cash
unless they are cashing gigantic matrix
of reed models for all the possible
combination of users and shipment
addresses and that's obviously not
doable at all that means that part of
this information this one specifically
must be able weighted on the fly and
probably sales could say something like
you know what I can cash prices for 10
minutes marketing says I can cash name
in descriptions for 6 month warehouse
can I cash inventory no can I cash
shipping information no that means now
that we have different services or
different actors in the system that are
now competing to invalid invalidate that
cash with different strategies so the
problem what the problem is if we have a
monolithic cache at this point and
someone like sales comes in and said
well 10 minutes just goes by went by so
invalidate that well but it's the entire
shopping cart
but I don't care invalidate it all and
now everyone needs to be involved to say
well refill the cash and marketing my
safe but I don't care I was doing
something else so it's not my business
now I'm not available right now
so we basically moved the coupling
somewhere else at a different time
without realizing it so basically as
soon as we have a central place what we
are doing is basically with violating
the single responsibility principle we
don't have a single responsibility
anymore even though we have these
amazing services laid out with hard
boundaries but the cash is basically
destroying everything that we did so far
what do we have if we look at this
picture the thing that is not that easy
to spot is that we have shared
identifiers so all these services they
share one thing the same primary key the
concept is shared and primary keys don't
change because if primary keys change we
have a much bigger problem and that's
not we don't need to bother with dealing
with that very matter
so and if we are in the in a business in
which primary keys might change well we
can come up with surrogate case and then
a translation mechanism in every service
in order to say well what is in URL from
the outside for me is a good idea for
someone else's dream for someone else is
an interior whatever so that's not the
problem we're trying to solve right now
given that we have share keys across
services can we use those those share
keys to relate in some way information
in order to compose on the fly if we
really need information to the user or
from the out for the outside that's
quite a view model composition for now
so we have a browser just use a sample
and a URL someone is hitting this roud
product slash one and that URL as an
interesting characteristic is a key in
that URL so if there
please share the across all services
then what we can do as basically a
school services hey give me your piece
of data related to this key and have
some kind of process that is capable of
on-the-fly building the expected view
model the shopping cart in this case and
then it give it back to the browser
so the flow if we want to come up with a
diagram representing what's going on
under the hood is something like this we
have services on the right and then we
have an incoming HTTP request on slash
product slash one that goes to what we
can call a composition gateway is it
it's it's a reverse proxy in the end so
it's someone that is intercepting all
the incoming requests to our
nice-looking back-end topology that we
want to hide away from the outside and
says is there anyone interested in
handling this specific request so it's a
kind of a query saying view services
over there there might be hundreds
is there anyone interested in entering
that specific request and in this case
these for and serious here is my handler
a piece of code that is capable of
anything of handling a request and now
what the reverse proxy does is well
compose basically for reaches in
parallel over time and say do your
business give me back your data that you
need to use to augment the view model
and just augment it so they go to their
back-end sir in whatever mean they want
in the sample I use HTTP and that
possibly the worst possible way but can
be done in many different ways they
receive data back that happens in
parallel and finally they compose the
view model that last can be returned to
the client so the client now asks for
the shopping cart or a product or for
whatever my account page and now
multiple services can kick in and say
well here you are
now what happens is that sales might
have a cashier where cash is pricing
information only for ten minutes in
which case this call doesn't hit the
sales back-end or the sales database
hits the sales cash that is now not
anymore in the land of nowhere but it's
owned by sales so there's full ownership
of every single piece in this slice
marketing might have a cache as well
where everything this cash for month and
if there's a type or there's someone
manually invalidating stuff in the cache
shipping and warehouse they have no cash
at all or put in this way let's say that
warehouse is a say P or sales force this
call goes to the ASAP API if this one or
to the Salesforce API we can do that at
that point mean that generalizing it we
can have the specific technology we need
or we must have or we must accept
because the enterprise decided that
sales for this solution for warehousing
and hide that away from clients without
the need of having something here the
cash that we define before that is owned
by no one so let's try to focus on price
using that as a sample what the code
could like look like oh is familiar is
she shot good everyone basically so I'm
glad so we might have something like
sales product request Sandler so we're
trying to handle these slash products as
left one request right so a class like
product details get handler that
implements this interface I handle
requests that has the match's behavior
so we are in the first phase of the
matching so there's an incoming URL we
can put the reverse proxy asks everyone
are you interested basically calls all
the matches implementation
and everyone will react saying well is
it a product's controller yes does it
contain a key yes so does it match a
router template yes I'm interested in
cell template fine
I'll return true and if I return true
what end is a get request so I can
intercept post put delete head whatever
if I return true that means that append
OP handle sorry will be cold later in
the process so what the composition get
with us now is creates an in-memory view
model that is basically dictionary I'm
using dynamic for the sake of the sample
can be whatever you want really let's
see the demo has oversimplified to keep
it simple and despite of that is 36
projects so I try to avoid as much as we
can infrastructure to remove that from
the equation and what the handle meter
does is accept this view model that from
his perspective could be empty doesn't
really care what's inside already in the
view model so retrieves from the URL the
ID goes to its own back and retrieves
the product price details augments the
view model
so basically we're a favor we go to the
backhander and finally augment the view
model we really can retrieve data from
whatever we want so there's nothing
really wrong in going to a database here
there's nothing really wrong in reading
a cache but in the text file whatever
it's up to you to do whatever you want
so that doesn't matter all the other
Pender's or requests handler will do the
same thing so basically in order to
build a product page there will be five
of this the product the marketing one
the pricing the sales one warehouse one
the what was that the shipping one and
so on and they will oh they will all
match the slash product slash key router
temple
they will only be invoked they will do
their stuff and they will all augment
the view model that is finally returned
to the client the client now as a JSON
kind of thing and can do whatever they
want and that's fine
we basically sold all the read problems
and we have now a user that is happy
that from a single page can understand
what's going on but I promise
what about rights then if you think
about it what we did is that we had the
quantity in three different places so
that means that when we are trying to
add something to the cart and as the
option drop down that allows me to
select the quantity or we are in the
shopping cart and we are trying to
change the quantity within some way to
inform three different services or more
that the quantity changed because all of
them need the quantity in order to be
able to pay their business to do their
business we can call that as you might
guess view model decomposition at this
point so what happens is that still web
browser is a sample and there's a post
request the post request goes to the
shopping cart and the post request
contains an item ID and the quantity
because that's the only thing that we
need at this point
so if data are already in the correct
place we just need the ID of the item
the product that we want to add to the
shopping cart views scattered around in
multiple services and the quantity
that's the only thing required to do the
next step so to bring the system in the
next consistent state so we post that
and as soon as we post that that should
go to abstract that should go to three
different services so they all need this
information in order to do their job
so in some way in here we need to be
able to decompose that information or
given the simplicity of this one
basically copy paste this information
three times into three different places
once again let's have a look at the code
first so shopping shipping shopping cart
request
handler so we're not looking at our good
look like and as you can imagine
probably sales and warehouse are exactly
the same so we have a still and I handle
requests this implementation that guess
what matches something we're matching a
post request to the shopping cart to the
add action because that's the way MVC
under the works under the hood works and
it must contain an ID that is the
shopping cart ID we're trying to add
stuff to so post request and when handle
is called what we're doing is we're
converting what's coming in from the
quest extracting data from the HTTP form
and we are creating this kind of let's
call it detail for now but in the end
we're sending that over a queue to the
backends so basically we're a
synchronously calling backends and all
the other two appenders handlers sorry
they do the same thing so they are
receiving the post request and they are
sending a synchronous messages to their
back and saying hey folks over there
someone added an item to the cart do
your stuff now why are we using a queue
at this point because five things might
go wrong obviously and in the
distributed system things go wrong all
the time we should design for failure so
what might happen is that at this point
there's an HTTP that's important this is
fine and oops this break now there's no
transaction here so HTTP someone
attempted that with the WS star standard
to introduce the WS transaction kind of
standard over HTTP it was a huge failure
so there's no transaction that is
capable of telling a you should be
atomically transactional
and trying to add to your backhands
information so the only option is to
basically delegate to a queue the fact
that someone should do this later on
what happened in that case what if we
could add a kind of I handle requests
her order to the interface to the class
saying hey if something goes wrong so if
the first one succeed but the second one
fails the first one should be interested
in knowing that something went wrong or
all the other actors in the actor should
be able to understand that well one of
us failed oh we don't care something
good went wrong so basically what
happens is that when the handle is cold
there's this request ID that we
basically ignored for now so that
request ID is received from the outside
and is passed along with the message
whenever something goes wrong the same
request ID has passed into the on
request error invocation so that means
that the composition gateway that is
handling our orchestration in quotes and
we'll get to that in a second is
basically keeping track of the incoming
request ID and saying do the things
hopeth something that went wrong
compensate or request error this request
ID and what they are doing is that the
game they are sending messages
so they're basically simply saying back
to their back-end clean up a failed
request message can be named whatever
you want
roll back whatever doesn't really matter
so we're basically saying at the back
end my back-end shipping please if you
ever received the previous request roll
it back
how can how does it work so think about
it think to a shopping cart you
basically have a shopping cart let's say
that for the sake of the sample does
just one item in the shopping cart so
there's one item in the shopping cart
and you're changing the quantity so it's
an update
operation on a table you're moving from
two to ten and now someone tells you
revert it back and your only option is
to answer what should I write back I
have no idea what I did before I have no
idea even if I did it because I might be
the one and that only back and failed so
you're asking me to refer to revert
something I never did is there a
solution to that the easiest one is
basically to say since we're passing
along this request ID everywhere we can
use that to keep track of requests so
going to the lowest possible level what
a table in shipping could look like we
have the cart ID that is always the same
so it's my cart ID we have product IDs
because we're changing the quantity for
example and we have quantities and we
have request IDs
so it's an append-only kind of model so
whenever we're trying to add an item to
the carton we don't update anything we
never update stuff in the back end we
just insert insert insert and whenever
we try to read we basically sum this and
we know that we have one four eight nine
items in the cart for this Product ID so
it's effectively a group I plus account
at reading time hey given that shipping
owns the entire model shipping can do
whatever they want in order to keep
track of this kind of changes and it
looks like event sourcing but it's not
quite event sourcing because we don't
need we don't want event sourcing in
this model event sourcing can be a
solution to this kind of problem and
there are scenarios the accounting
scenario working this way and from the
accounting perspective unless you are
Italian and we're recording I know you
cannot rely delete anything so Italian
scan rules are made to be broken you
know so it means that in an accounting
kind of service you want a transition
from an append-only model
- probably an event sourced model where
instead of deleting a role in case of a
failed request Europe ending another row
with the negative information so if I
want to delete this attempt I'm going to
append another one win minus one and
that Betsy decompensate if I'm going to
compensate this there will be another
one with minus four but given that
shipping doesn't really care about
keeping track of what users were doing
while managing the card shipping can
simply wipe the row and delete it that's
good enough for chipping perspective if
shipping was the failing one shipping
will receive a compensate request and
say well I never did it so I can safely
ignore the thing and basically continue
working
I was the failing one but I'm sorry
basically I don't need to compensate the
important thing of what we observed so
far is that there's no orchestration at
all anywhere so the two phase
composition approach or decomposition
approach matching + handle make so that
makes us so that the composition gateway
or the reverse proxy looking at it from
the technical technological perspective
knows nothing about handlers so it's
simply using dependency injection or
inversion of control to say is there
anyone interested in this if yes do your
stuff and come back to me when you're
done I'll wait for you because I have an
incoming HTTP request to satisfy if
there's no one one one one only or
10,000 well ten thousand maybe it's a
problem but ten of them doesn't matter
the composition get to it doesn't need
to say marketing do this for me sales do
this for me shipping do this for me it's
up to them to decide I wanna be part of
this request so otherwise this coupling
so whenever you have an Orchestrator you
have coupling once again because if the
business comes and say well on the
product page you know what I want to be
able to display related products that's
another pender in the game basically
but if we need to change the orchestra
tour now we have coupling once again
because there must be an Orchestrator
team that we need to knock the door and
say Fulks please can you do this for me
and they might reply no we cannot deploy
now we're in the process of a big change
it will take six months up I'm sorry
about that let's see the problem of
coupling especially the largest the
system is lower coupling you want and
that's the thing you need to fear and
escape from whatever shift so far one
interesting thing that is called full
vertical slices so we're now able to say
each service or micro service or
autonomous component call it whatever
you want it doesn't really matter all
the behavior and data and the view model
composition part basically Bui right so
the part that represents the shape of
the data from the user perspective I'd
like to stress a little bit on the
behavior and data I should remove data
from this slide you might respect from
my perspective one of the biggest
mistake domain driven design leads
people to is thinking that data is the
important part
whether behavior is the important part
data are just a side effect of behavior
we're modeling behaviors of people we're
not modeling the shopping cart we're
modeling the fact that the fact that
people wants to add items to the cart
they want to remove items from the cart
change quantity buy stuff and things
like that the fact that in order to do
that we need to store information on
discs because we need to reboot machines
it's a technical implementation detail
behavior is the only important thing or
the most important thing so we if we
start thinking about behaviors only then
we will end up with nice bandwidth
because behaviors are bounded by default
I need this information that are private
to me in order to achieve this goal
that's it
however it's not that easy once again so
as soon as we have hard boundaries we
realize that in some way services needs
to talk to each other huh so what let's
try to look at
2news business to new business
requirements the business come and say
well I'd like to notify users if they
had something in the cart for one week
and they did nothing it's a kind of
pressure on you
bye-bye-bye or what if they never come
back after a month let's say we wipe the
cards because we we value space on their
scan we want to delete it
it's just I'm just making up things so
we have this scenario and we we need
some way to allow services to talk to
each other because conceptually we said
that sales on the shopping cart so the
add operation is conceptually owned by
sales it says that is the one that is
responsible from the business
perspective for the shopping cart
concept so the add to cart item whenever
we add something to the cart sales sets
a one-week timeout and Adam will talk
more about coding in the future later
today so if you're interested in how
this thing works and what you can do
with that join him and since at the same
time set a one-month timeout to do the
second operation white card when the
first timeout expires says raises in
event that is something happened a cart
got stale and that event goes on to a
basa that is entered by marketing that
does one thing I know I the user with an
image
so they're basically sending a
notification saying hey you have lot
left overs over there are you interested
in them after a month the card will
expire there and that's interesting for
basically all the services in this case
I'm using just two of them is a sample
so warehousing shipping needs to wipe
their vision of the card because we have
the cart now that is
dispersed across multiple services so
they need to be aware of the fact that
the card needs to be deleted to some
extent we don't really need it because
if sales is the one owning the car tidy
concept we can basically simply delete
the card from sales and we're going to
have our phones here they won't ever be
queried by anyone we're just wasting
space there can be a bad job at late
night that every month look at our
phones cards and wipe them but you got
the point so if you if if we want we can
notify other services that something
happened and it happened is very
important so it's something that is in
the past immutable that cannot change
and they can react to that doing
whatever you do whatever they want the
very important bit that all what we said
so far discloses is that now events can
be as fin as event name and IDs we don't
need fake events anymore that's the
horrible name the industry uses so we
don't need to share information at all
if data are private to services and they
are already in the place they need to be
we don't need to put daytona queue we
don't need to have coupling traveling on
a queue because we just need to say
that's done here is the ID of the thing
that I did and since we said these are
stable they won't change that event
won't ever change if it changes it
because there's a disruptive business
change at a certain point the business
says well we don't use shopping carts
anymore that's not a technical problem
so or Amazon started selling cars in
Italy it's not like selling this thing
it's selling yes but the business
process is so completely different that
is basically a brand new company behind
the scenes don't the final big picture
of this is something like an we have
services they have behaviors and data
and then there's a
bus that acts like a communication layer
under the hood that allows services to
exchange theme events so just names and
ID's the minimum required to make other
people understand what happened and then
they have a food on in the UI using this
view model composition technique so
unfortunately we have very little time
at conferences so if you're interested
in seeing this live there's a demo
composed of 36 projects that demos the
these four business requirements of the
shopping cart so you get out complex it
can be and if you want to dive more into
service boundaries here is a link up to
a set of videos from who did the hand
that is my boss by the way talking about
boundaries so to conclude which are the
takeaways here so let's talk a little
bit about what we can extract from what
we talked about so far
bandura's are they really the key to
success it's nice to listen to Eric
Evans saying if I would write the book
today I would put service bond or a
compounded context at the beginning of
the book because that's the most
important concept that should go through
before even starting to think about an
implementation if you get bandura
stronger it's not going to end well
I'm sorry about that but it's it's good
it's the first step into the coupling
word so you really need to get service
boundaries if you're talking about SOA
you're bonded contacts if we're talking
about domain driven design right
otherwise it's very easy to fall into
the trap of coupling one of the things
that I use to signal myself so maybe
something is wrong as every single time
I have this desire to add new technology
to solve a problem let's go back to the
whiteboard we might god boundaries wrong
so technology is never a solution to
business problems business people they
don't talk about technology ever they
won't ever tell you can we catch that
information for a while and if they did
change the business so they don't care
about technology they talk about
behaviors we introduce technology to try
to compensate for things that we did
wrong in the past so be aware of that
the other thing that I realized in my
career is that the user mental model
that at the center point we celebrate
that Wow we need to implement the user
mental model can badly influenced your
design users and business stakeholders
they tend to talk about the way they see
that on screens the way they perceive
the information flowing inside the
application they don't they don't talk
about boundaries it's up to us to
understand in the way they talk about
something where boundaries can be
identified so that does an important
role in the industry that is the
information architect so UX people does
UX people that dedicate their life to
information architecture they are the
key actor that needs to be brought in
very quickly that is kind of mediator
between the business people talking
someone knowing how to translate that
into a UI UI in the general sense or
behaviors on a screen and that is the
one that can say well I know that this
information doesn't really belong to the
card what should go there and stuff like
that so that's something you usually
tend to forget about so we transition
immediately to someone saying we have a
shopping cart public class a shopping
cart with lists of ID public list of
shopping cart items items and we're
doomed at that point we toast it
so the third thing where do not name
things prematurely that's the hardest
part as I said a business stakeholder
says well this product public's class
product we have customers public class
customer a customer has a name public
string name and the customer has a
status
public kind of anomer status and then
the third thing they say is when every
sells something the price depends on the
customer status if they are a gold
customer 10% discount and now we have
coupling because customers are owned by
the CRM and products are owned by sales
from the pricing perspective and we
never knew to me we need to show a price
we need to combine information coming
from two different boundaries coupling
once again so behaviors define how to
aggregate data group data that change
together in the same boundary whenever
we have data cooperating with the
behavior in order to produce an output
whatever output that is is a message an
event that on a screen doesn't matter
data that change together should stay
together they are looking at it from the
technical perspective they are
transactional boundaries so it's
important to respect the instructional
boundaries and they should stay together
but if you think about previous sample
if you have the customer status and the
price that should stay together because
they they participate in defining the
the selling price on the website how do
you name that there isn't a class that
can be deemed priced based on customer
status class doesn't make any sense
that's a policy that's a behavior with
modeling that's a kind of a rule that we
are modeling in the system that that's
its own bandura probably isolated from
the others because they change together
and finally use UI composition
techniques to brings everything back
together in the UI because that's the
end goal so one of the end goals we want
to be able to allow users to play nicely
with our UI without depending on things
like postman if you ask my wife to use
postman that probably doesn't lis end
well so they want a nice looking at UI
with the product their mental model ends
up in the UI and stays there in a
distributed system the the
all of the system in the backend doesn't
really fit the user mental model so we
need to be aware of that so my name is
Mario Sorrenti I work for tactical
software as a solution architect there
are some information and thank you very
much
[Applause]